Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the book of prayer from
regarding the times which are prohibited
for a person to pray during these times
and the exceptions to these prohibited
times of prayer. And we mention that
the exceptions
to the rule of proh prohibited prayer
during the three times which is
after fud before and after or before
respectively.
We mentioned
the general rule of that which is ex as
of that which is an exception
to these three times is what
zan and mak any
prayer that is specific to a time a
place or an occasion.
Right. And we've mentioned an example of
a time is when
right until the im is on the and an
ex an exception due to a place is
huh
for instance
Mecca
or oram
thea correct And we
mentioned
those two. Now we will discuss a
sebub which is an occasion right an
exception which is an occasion. It's
connected to an occasion. It'sa it's
connected to something that happens such
as
such as
right.
for
[Silence]
And so the author tells us that a prayer
which
is prohibited during these three times
of prohibition is what is intended ended
by this prohibition is general optional
prayer just general optional prayer I'm
just praying because I feel praying
these are the only three times in which
salah is prohibited as for a prayer that
is specific to a time place or occasion
or a prayer which is
being made up right person sleeps
through a prayer forgets a prayer then
this is exempt
from the prohibition
whether it is an obligatory player pray
prayer or optional prayer meaning if a
person makes and forgets to make the
sunnah salah
when can they make it up anytime they
remember
they can make it up even if it's after
10 days they can make it up as soon as
they remember that's the time to make up
a forgotten prayer Right? We've
discussed this regarding obligatory
prayer. The same applies for optional
[Arabic recitation]
An occasion an an instance of that is
making after making due to the narration
of in which the prophet
was said to bal one
morning at
oh bal tell me what is an action that
you have done and been consistent in
doing
that you are more hopeful to be rewarded
for by Allah because I heard the sound
of your footsteps in front of me in
paradise. And Bel then mentions he says
I have not done any action consistently
any act of worship consistently
that I am more hopeful for the reward
for from Allah ex the act of
every time I purify myself meaning make
or
I whether it's day or night of any hour
of the day or night except cept that I
will pray after doing so. I never just
make wudoo and just leave it until the
next prayer. I always make wudoo make
make salah right after. And so the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
acknowledged this and he affirmed it
right notice the wording of he says any
time of the day of or night whether
that's after before or before
and likewise the author mentions as well
and so the point here is as we've
mentioned in the past few days we've
taken a lot of time to clarify
these
prohibitions And to clarify these
exceptions, this is a very important
chapter
and topic in f right and that is that we
learn the prohibition but then we learn
its exceptions. We learn the obligations
but then we learn its exceptions. This
is so important because the worst thing
a person could do is learn half
of the issue.
Learn half of the issue. Learning half
of something creates a full measure of
problems.
As we've mentioned before, what is the
greatest enemy to knowledge?
What is the greatest enemy to knowledge?
Compounded ignorance. Not just
ignorance. Ignorance isn't a problem.
You could fix ignorance very easily. Is
that not correct?
Ignorance. Someone doesn't know
something, you teach them. That's it. We
We fixed it. Right. The problem is
compounded ignorance. A person doesn't
know something and they don't think that
they don't know it. They believe that
they completely know it. How can you
teach someone this? Right? This is
what happens when we learn half of
something. When we learn the half, we
don't learn the the whole picture. A lot
of confusion sets in. So these
exceptions to the rules are just as
important as learning the rules
themselves
because it's not the point is not to
just understand what the prophet said.
Anybody can do that. It's to understand
what he said in the way that he intended
it. That's the difference between
scholars and and half measures,
right? Is they understand it as he
intended. It's not to understand the
Quran. Everyone who reads the Quran
understanded, understands it, but it's
to understand the Quran as Allah meant
for it to be understood. Only the
scholars do that. And there's only one
correct way to do that, right?
[Arabic recitation]